[Musique]
simone adore faire sécher ses vêtements
sur sa corde à linge mais les branches
de l'arbre du voisin sont envahissantes
la corde à linge et parfois collants et
ses vêtements parfois slipper simmons
demande à son voisin de couper les
branches mais il refuse pour le forcer
et n'a d'autre choix que de demander une
injonction à la cour supérieure elle
trouve ça trop compliqué trop cher et en
plus elle n'est pas sûre de gagner car
on ne coupe plus les arbres pour mille
et une raisons comme dans l'ancien temps
un jour où son voisin est absent simone
décide de se faire justice elle-même
mauvaise idée maintenant est le voisin
sur le dos il la poursuit pour lui
réclamer les dommages qu'il a causés à
son arbre le fin mot de l'histoire où la
présence des arbres créé des différents
difficile à trancher avant de craquer
réfléchissez